So, Paul.
>> Mm?
>> It seems like it's probably worth
reiterating the time allowances for
each of the stages in RAIL.
>> You mean LIAR.
>> Even better.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Okay, LIAR stands for load, idle,
animations, and responsiveness.
During the load stage you have about one
second or a thousand milliseconds to
render the page before the app
no longer feels responsive, and
the user's attention level falls.
Download and
render your critical resources here.
After loading, the app is idle, and
this is a great time to do
non-essential work to ensure that
whatever interactions occur after
this period will feel instantaneous.
Your app's idle time should be broken
down into 50 millisecond chunks so
that you can stop when
the user starts interacting.
>> During the animation stage,
such as when users are scrolling or
animations are occurring, you only have
16 milliseconds to render a frame.
This is when 60 frames per
second is absolutely critical.
>> Lastly, there's the response period.
The human mind has about 100
milliseconds' grace period
before an interaction with
the site feels laggy and janky.
That means your app needs to
respond to user input in some way
within a 100 milliseconds.
Using this time wisely is
absolutely critical for
setting up difficult animations
that run at 60 frames a second.
>> In the next few quizzes, you'll be
asked to apply what you've learned about
RAIL in some real-world scenarios.